[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER HEIDEN: OK.
Today we will start
our discussion of--
with a discussion of
glycolysis as a pathway
and how we can use favorable
oxidation of glucose
to enable phosphate addition
while at the same time
producing useful
intermediates that
enable us to do ATP synthase--
ATP synthesis and maintain a
high ATP-ADP ratio in cells.
Now I drew up here the
entire glycolytic pathway,
just like you saw at the
end of the last lecture,
and I want to go through
it here step by step.
And so the first
step in glycolysis,
as we already talked
about, is we have glucose.
This here is, of course,
alpha-D-Glucose in the--
I drew it in the alpha form.
If the OH was pointing up, that
would be the beta form, just
some quick review.
I'll drop the alpha and beta
and the stereochemistry denotion
going forward.
This glucose molecule, as
we discussed previously,
is first trapped in cells
by being phosphorylated
by the enzyme hexokinase,
sometimes abbreviated HK,
to give glucose 6-phosphate.
Not shown here, this
glucose 6-phosphate
then undergoes an
isomerase reaction
via the open chain form.
Again, we discussed
this reaction
when we discussed sugars.
And so this would be catalyzed
by glucose phosphate isomerase,
and takes it from the
aldose to the ketose,
and now you have the
fructose-- the ketose fructose
6-phosphate shown here
in the furanose form.
This fructose 6-phosphate
is then phosphorylated
a second time by an enzyme
called phosphofructokinase,
typically abbreviated PVK.
It's phosphorylated on the
1 position to give fructose
1,6-bisphosphate, shown here.
That fructose 1,6-bisphosphate
can then be cleaved via
the enzyme aldolase.
Cleavage takes place in the open
chain form which I drew up here
in the corner.
Basically splitting
the molecule in half
to form two trioses, one
of which is the ketose
dihydroxyacetone phosphate,
basically the top half
of the molecule.
The other is the bottom
half of the molecule,
the aldose glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
These two trioses can be
interconverted, the aldose
and the ketose via on isomerase.
The enzyme that
does that is called
trioses phosphate isomerase.
And moving forward basically
takes the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate that comes from
the top half and can turn all
the carbon from fructose
1,6-bisphosphate into two
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates.
That glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
as we discussed last time,
is the substrate for
the GAPDH reaction,
the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase, GAPDH.
which, as we
discussed last time,
couples oxidation
of this aldehyde
to this acid with
phosphate addition.
That oxidation reaction, the
electrons have to go somewhere,
that's where the
cofactor NAD comes in.
Picks up two electrons,
generates NADH,
and in the process, this
enzyme generates this molecule,
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate
or 1,3-BPG.
Remember, that 1,3-BPG
molecule was one of the useful
intermediates whereby we could
undergo favorable synthesis
of ATP even at the high
ATP-ADP ratio found in cells,
and that's because we can
transfer the phosphate from
this acid group onto ADP.
That gives us an ATP and the
product 3-phosphoglycerate 3-PG
carried out by the enzyme
phosphoglycerate kinase.
That 3-PG molecule
can then undergo
what's referred to
as a mutase reaction.
And so the phosphate
is moved from the 3
to the 2 position of glycerate.
So 3-phosphoglycerate
to 2-phosphoglycerate,
carried out by phosphoglycerate
mutase, often abbreviated PGAM.
This 2-phosphoglycerate can
then undergo a dehydration
to-- by an enzyme enolase
to give the molecule
phosphoenolpyruvate. .
Phosphoenolpyruvate
was the second
of those useful
intermediates that
allow ATP synthesis despite the
high ATP-ADP ratio in cells,
and that reaction, as
we already discussed,
is carried out by
pyruvate kinase
and allows you to
generate another ATP.
Now, as I drew out the
glycolytic pathway here,
I also listed the delta G0
prime for every single step
in the reaction.
Remember, this is informative
as to the equilibrium for each
of these individual reactions.
You'll note that for
many of the steps,
that delta G0 prime is positive.
Remember what that means.
That means that equilibrium
favors the left.
That is the reverse direction
of the entire pathway.
However, if you add
all of these up,
the delta G0 prime for
the entire pathway--
so delta G0 prime for the entire
pathway, glucose to pyruvate
adds up to negative
6.9 kcals per mole.
And so that negative 6.9 means
that for the entire pathway,
equilibrium favors the right.
So glucose to pyruvate,
the right direction.
And that is why this can
work as an overall pathway
even though some of the
individual steps, equilibrium
may favor the
opposite direction.
Now you'll notice that there's
several favorable steps where
delta G0 prime is
quite negative.
Pyruvate kinase,
phosphoglycerate kinase,
hexokinase, phosphofructokinase.
As we talked about before,
these are able to pull the less
favorable steps upstream forward
by keeping concentrations
of products such as
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate low,
thus allowing this net
reaction to move forward.
You'll notice I drew three
steps here as irreversible--
hexokinase, phosphofructokinase,
and pyruvate kinase.
Remember, these are
all reactions in our--
there's no such thing as
an irreversible reaction.
There are some conditions
where the reverse reaction,
of course, can happen.
Although remember, this--
when we discussed irreversible
in metabolism, what
we're referring to
is irreversible under
physiological conditions-- that
is, conditions found in cells.
You'll notice that
those three steps
are three of the four steps
that have very negative delta
G0 prime.
And so you would
expect that if we
were going to reverse
those reactions,
you would need some
kind of energy input,
and you'll see later that these
are the control points or also
regulated steps in this pathway.
And there are also the
sites, just to give you
a preview, that
we're going to have
to deal with if we're going
to try to synthesize glucose,
gluconeogenesis, the
reverse of glycolysis.
Now of course, these
delta G0 primes
are very informative of
what happens at equilibrium,
but of course, what
actually happens in a cell
or in any condition,
remember, is
dependent on the
equilibrium constant,
but also on the conditions.
Remember, it's delta G, delta
G equals delta G0 prime plus RT
times the log of the
products over the reactants.
And so delta G is
what really matters
for any individual
reactions, and what's
shown here on this
slide is basically
a approximate delta G0 change
across the glycolytic pathway
based on someone's approximation
of the conditions found
in cells.
Now we can see and
looking at this
that there's really three
big drops in delta G
across the pathway.
Here's the hexokinase
reaction, here's
the phosphofructokinase
reaction,
here's the pyruvate
kinase reaction.
And so it makes sense
that these would be,
then, the irreversible
steps because there
is what is actually pulling
the pathway forward.
It also makes sense that
one would exert control
at each of these
steps, because this
is what drives the flux
of the pathway forward,
but it's also where it's
difficult to go back.
Once you get here on this
flat part of the curve
energetically it doesn't
matter so much which
direction you go
along the curve,
but to try to climb back
up each of these hills
becomes difficult. And so
we'll revisit this later
in the lecture, but
this is basically
where the control
points will end up
happening in this pathway.
Now, I want to note a
couple other features
about this pathway,
and that is that we had
to invest some energy early.
You see you cost an
ATP at the hexokinase
and the phosphofructokinase
step and then
you harvest that ATP much later
at the phosphoglycerate kinase
and the pyruvate kinase steps.
The textbook typically
will split glycolysis
into what they refer to as
two stages, an investment
stage and a harvesting
stage, and that basically
relates to that fact.
And that's because you have a
glucose molecule that then you
use to generate two trioses.
And then each of
those trioses can
be used to generate
a pyruvate molecule.
And so it costs 2 ATP to
generate those to trioses,
but then each triose generated
allows you to recapture 2 ATPs.
And so what that means,
then, is that the net output
from glycolysis is 2 ATPs.
And so glucose going
to two glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates costs you, whereas
using those two glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates to
generate two pyruvates
allows you to recover 4 ATP for
a net of plus 2 ATP molecules
produced per
glucose metabolized.
Now if we add up the entire
stoichiometry of what's
going on here, we can
also draw it another way,
and that is we can
basically have glucose
plus 2 ATP molecules plus
2 inorganic phosphates,
goes to 2 pyruvates
plus 2 ATP, and that's
because we're able
to incorporate
2 phosphate molecules
here at the GAPDH step.
Now that's great, but if
you're paying attention,
you notice that we're
missing one other thing
in this stoichiometry,
and that's
that cofactor NAD that was also
required to maintain electron
balance across the GAPDH step.
And so remember that for
these pathways to work,
we have to balance all
things that are going in
with all things
are going out-- we
can't create or destroy matter.
And so those electrons
have to be dealt with.
When we discussed the
GAPDH reaction last time,
we needed that cofactor NAD
in order to act as an acceptor
for the electrons to allow
that oxidative phosphorylation,
if you will, of
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
to 1,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
And so in order for
this pathway to work,
we need a way to regenerate
that NADH back to an NAD
in order to make
electron balance.
In other words, we have
to deal with the fact
that we've generated--
or that we required 2 NAD+ to
run this pathway and generate 2
NADH.
And so we need a way to get rid
of those electrons from NADH
to regenerate that NAD and allow
the pathway to be balanced.
Now it should be
clear that this has
to happen stoichiometrically for
every single glucose molecule
that goes through glycolysis.
That is, we have to regenerate
2 NAD plusses for every glucose
that we're going to
convert into 2 pyruvates.
And so for this NADH
reoxidation to occur,
we need a place to transfer
those two electron pairs.
And so just like any oxidation
and reduction reaction,
if we're going to oxidize
NADH back to NAD+,
something else
has to be reduced,
and that thing has to be reduced
stoichiometrically with every
single pyruvate that's produced
from glucose and glycolysis.
And effectively you
will see that this
is the role of fermentation.
It's an ability for us to
solve this redox problem,
that we have to dispose of
those electrons in the oxidation
at the GAPDH step in order
to deal with this electron
waste of the pathway.
Now, the useful
way to do this is
that we're generating a
pyruvate stoichiometrically.
And so we can use that
stoichiometrically,
that product pyruvate by
reducing it to form the waste
product, and that's effectively
what fermentation is.
It's turning that pyruvate
into ethanol or lactate, which
is reducing that pyruvate,
picking up the electron
waste from the
NADH, and allowing
you to regenerate the NAD that's
required to run the GAPDH step.
And so I'll just
illustrate this.
The simplest fermentation
reaction that we can do
is the run that's
done by animals,
and that's to generate lactate.
And so to just illustrate
this explicitly, here is--
so this here would be the
reduced form of NAD, NADH.
So this here this--
this is the nicotinamide group.
Remember, it's hooked
up to an ADP ribose
to give nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide in the reduced
form.
So this can transfer
electrons to pyruvate.
Here's pyruvate.
So as we showed last time,
we can take 2 electrons
from NADH reduced.
That gives us this hydride ion,
which can generate lactate.
Plus, what we're left
with is the oxidized form
of the cofactor NAD+.
And now this NAD+ can be reduced
back to NADH at the GAPDH step,
and the electrons from NADH, as
it's being reoxidized to NAD,
can go and take pyruvate
and reduce it to lactate.
So NAD gets reoxidized to NAD.
Pyruvate now gets-- the ketone
gets reduced to the alcohol
as you go from
pyruvate to lactate.
Opposite of what's going
on in the GAPDH step.
There, the aldehyde is
oxidized to the acid,
while NAD+ oxidized goes--
is reduced to NADH.
Here, NADH is reoxidized to
NAD while taking the pyruvate
and re-reducing it to lactate.
This, by adding here, allows
us now to regain balance
across the entire pathway.
This step is catalyzed by the
enzyme lactate dehydrogenase,
often abbreviated LDH.
And that allows regenerating
the NAD+ that's needed
for the GAPDH step, which
allows us to deal with
the stoichiometry problem
of the entire pathway.
And so what fermentation
does for cells
is allows electron
disposal by taking
the product of the
pathway pyruvate,
reducing it stoichiometrically
to form a reduced product--
as shown here, lactate,
and that allows
you to maintain electron balance
across the entire pathway.
And so this entire fermentation
pathway, glucose to lactate,
now allows the generation of
the net generation of 2 ATP
and run this pathway
in cells so cells
can maintain a high ATP-ADP
ratio by fermenting glucose
into lactate.
Now, if you're paying
attention, this also
now begins to describe
why it is that oxygen
is such a useful
molecule for metabolism
and actually why it's
quite key to supporting
the bioenergetics of cells.
And so recall, oxygen was
there when we burned wood
and we used that example.
And why oxygen is so important
for burning wood, why
it's important for doing
glucose catabolism in our cells
is that oxygen is a really
great electron acceptor.
That is, I can draw out oxygen
can take 2 electrons that
are generated as
NADH waste, if you
want to call it
that, plus protons,
and this generates water.
And so an alternative
to fermentation in order
to allow glucose oxidation is
rather than do fermentation,
is to transfer those
electrons to oxygen
to run the pathway another way.
In other words, if we write
glucose to pyruvate and realize
that this is an
oxidation reaction,
and so therefore,
generates electron
waste in the form of NADH that
has to be recycled to NAD,
we can do so by putting
those reoxidizing NADH,
means something else
has to be reduced.
This something else could
be oxygen as a good electron
acceptor to be reduced to water
and find an alternative place
to put those electrons.
Or, if oxygen is
not present, now we
can do fermentation, turning
pyruvate into lactate.
It should be clear
that if we want
to completely oxidize
glucose, as in burning wood--
that is, turn it--
all the carbon and glucose
into the most oxidized form
of carbon, CO2,
this also requires
places to put electrons.
That is, we could
generate more NADH.
And of course, each
of those electrons
have to be dealt with.
And the final home
for those electrons
needs to be something
that's a good electron
acceptor like oxygen, allowing
you to continually reoxidize
your NADH by reducing
oxygen to water.
So, in the absence
of fermentation,
oxygen can be used to
maintain electron balance,
and of course,
much more energy is
going to be released if
we completely burn glucose
than if we only partially
oxidize glucose.
And this is why oxygen
allows more energy
to be released,
or, as you probably
learned in high school,
more ATP to be produced
from glucose metabolism.
Now the details of
how all of this works
are much more complicated
than what I have drawn.
Obviously fermentation
happens the way I drew it,
but all the other details
about the role of oxygen
and how it fits in
to these pathways
is more complicated
than what I've drawn,
and we'll cover this in
the upcoming lectures.
But the key concept
is here, and that
is the relationship between
oxygen and fermentation
is really what's
illustrated here.
These are two different
ways that cells
can use to dispose of
the electron waste that's
produced from carbon oxidation
and glucose metabolism.
Those electrons have
to go somewhere.
They can go to the
product of glycolysis,
say pyruvate to lactate,
by lactate dehydrogenase,
reduce the pyruvate to
lactate, fermentation,
or they can go somewhere else.
A great electron
acceptor like oxygen
which allows these
pathways to happen
while saving the pyruvate
to do something else,
like be completely
oxidized to CO2.
Now it should be
clear here, then,
that one of the things that's
special about fermentation
is that absolutely no oxygen
is required to do this,
and this is part of the reason
why this pathway is so ancient.
Fermentation evolved in
the pre-oxygen atmosphere,
and that really is why it's
such an ancient pathway.
Only when oxygen levels
rose in the atmosphere
due to photosynthesis that
enough oxygen was around that
then other oxidative pathways
could evolve as an alternative
to fermentation.
Now, you'll note that
the original description
of fermentation by Pasteur
was ethanol, not lactate.
We'll cover the details
of ethanol in a minute,
but I just want to point out
that making ethanol instead
of lactate is simply
an alternative product
to dispose of pyruvate as
a more reduced product.
So ethanol is a more reduced
product than pyruvate
in that ethanol generation is
an additional adaptation that
allows you to dispose
of the electron waste
while also generating a molecule
that's toxic, and therefore,
allow organisms that make
ethanol to better kill off
their neighbors and
their environment
and compete for resources.
But the overall
concept is identical.
Ethanol is really an alternative
to lactate and fermentation
but solves exactly
the same problem.
I want to talk about ethanol
metabolism in more detail,
but before we do that first
I want to go through and just
describe at a very high level
some of the chemistry that
allows all these reactions
in glycolysis to work,
because you'll see that
the chemistry itself is not
all that complicated even
though we can draw it
and it seems like
somewhat overwhelming
when drawn out as
a whole pathway.
Now I want to point
out, we've already
covered the chemistry
for a lot of these steps.
First of all, there's two
dehydrogenase reactions.
There's GAPDH and there's
lactate dehydrogenase.
Here's the mechanism for
lactate dehydrogenase,
it's a hydride transfer.
The same thing happened at GAPDH
with the additional details
of adding the phosphate.
We covered that previously
in an earlier lecture.
Note, we also covered before
the chemistry of pyruvate kinase
and phosphoglycerate kinase.
In addition, there's two
more kinase reactions
that exist here, hexokinase
and phosphofructokinase.
These are really just
straightforward phosphotransfer
reactions using ATP to
transfer a phosphate.
Very straightforward,
exactly what
Professor Yaffe has already
talked to you about,
about how one does
phosphotransfer
for kinase reactions
on proteins.
Now, two other steps
are isomerase reactions,
triose phosphatase isomerase
and glucose phosphate isomerase.
We discussed this chemistry back
when we did the sugar lectures.
This is just acting on the open
chain form of the carbohydrate
and allows you to interconvert
between the ketose
and the aldose as I already
drew during that lecture.
And so that just
leaves a few steps
left to discuss that
we can cover briefly.
The first one that
we'll talk about
is this enolase reaction,
which is simply a dehydration.
I'll draw it here just to be
explicit as to what's going on.
So here is 2-phosphoglycerate.
Simply dehydration
to remove water,
and that gives us
phosphoenolpyruvate, PEP.
The next step I want to discuss,
phosphoglycerate mutase,
is an example of a mutase
reaction that is, remember,
it's moving the
phosphate from the 3
to the 2 position of glycerate.
This is a class of reactions.
It has somewhat of an
interesting mechanism.
And basically precedes
by a phosphorylated
enzyme intermediate.
In the case of phosphoglycerate
mutase, this is a histidine,
and so there is a histidine
with a nitrogen on it
in the active site.
And effectively, this nitrogen
can pick up a phosphate and be
primed via a reaction involving
a molecule you've seen already
from your discussion of
hemoglobin with Professor
Yaffe, and that's
2,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
And so again, here's--
this is glycerate phosphorylated
on the 2 and 3 position.
So this is
2,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
And effectively, this molecule
can bind in the active site
and pick up a
phosphate from either
of the 2 or the 3 position.
I drew it here is picking
it up from the 2 position.
That would, of course,
generate a 3-phosphoglycerate.
But more importantly, it
ends up with the enzyme
having this phosphorylated
intermediate
in the active site.
Once it has that
phosphorylated intermediate
in the active site, now
it's ready to catalyze
the mutase reaction.
So I'll draw here
first, this here
would be 3-phosphoglycerate.
Color the phosphate so you
can see what's going on.
This would basically, in the
active site of the enzyme,
pick up the phosphate from
the active site and generate
transiently this
2,3-bisphosphoglycerate
intermediate, and then it can
retransfer the phosphate from
the other position back on to
the active site of the enzyme
so it's ready to carry out
another catalytic cycle,
and in the process, move the
phosphate effectively from
the 3 position to
the 2 position.
So you'll see that the
phosphate is not actually
being-- the same
phosphate is not
being moved within
the same molecule,
it's being ping-ponged
back and forth
off of this phosphate
enzyme intermediate,
and basically this is how
cells catalyze various mutase
reactions to move phosphates
between hydroxyl groups.
And so you have to
prime this once with
a separately-generated
2,3-bisphosphoglycerate,
but once you have that
phosphorylated enzyme
in the active site, it can
now continually ping-pong that
phosphate around to effectively
convert 3-phosphoglycerate
to 2-phosphoglycerate, or
an example of another mutase
reaction, move the phosphate
between two other hydroxyl
groups on the same molecule.
OK.
Now the final reaction that we
haven't talked about is this
one, the aldolase reaction,
which is a really key step
in glycolysis because it splits
that carbon-carbon bond to take
the hexose--
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate,
and split it into two trioses,
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
which ultimately allows you
to make this pathway work.
And so I'll take you quickly
through how aldolase works.
So aldolase also has this
amine in the active site.
So here's FBP drawn in
the open chain form.
So you end up with
this intermediate
in the active site, which
can undergo this chemistry
to split this into the--
remove the lower
half of the molecule.
So you can see
here, this generates
this lower half of the molecule,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
as well as the top half,
which can regenerate
the active site, as well
as the other product,
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
And so very briefly, that's
effectively the chemistry that
allows aldolase to carry
out this important reaction
in glycolysis, splitting that
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate
into the aldose,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
and the ketose
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
OK.
So that is effectively
the chemistry that
allows you to turn
glucose into pyruvate,
as well as pyruvate
into lactate,
but what about making ethanol?
How does that work?
Now ethanol is an alternative
fermentative product.
And so the reactions to make
ethanol is basically this.
So here's pyruvate.
First thing that happens
is we lose this CO2.
Without a change in oxidation
state at the second carbon
at the ketone in pyruvate.
And so this ketone stays
the same oxidation state,
it's now an aldehyde.
This is a molecule
called acetaldehyde.
And now we can pick up those two
electrons from NADH and reduce
this aldehyde to the alcohol,
reoxidizing that NADH back
to NAD+ and generating
ethyl alcohol or ethanol.
So, the fermentative part
is turning the acetaldehyde
into the ethanol because that
allows you to dispose of those
two electrons, reduce the
aldehyde to an alcohol while
reoxidizing the NADH to an NAD+,
which is what allows glycolysis
to continue so that NAD+ is
available for the GAPDH step.
How this reaction works is--
I just drew it.
It's exactly how the
lactate dehydrogenase works.
However, what we also
now need to discuss
is how you carry
out this reaction,
this carboxylation to take
this CO2 off of pyruvate
and make acetaldehyde.
Now decarbonization
reactions are really
common reactions in metabolism.
They end up being important
for lots of pathways.
Obviously if we're going to
completely oxidize glucose
into CO2, we have to
remove CO2 for a molecule,
and here's the first one--
first one that we're going
to see for how that happens.
Now there's two
general mechanisms
that metabolism uses for
decarboxylation reactions,
and I want to introduce the
concept here of both of them.
Now, the first one
here is that these
are referred to as
decarboxylation reactions that
occur in the context
of either an alpha keto
acid or a beta keto acid.
Now, what do I mean by that?
Well, pyruvate is
an alpha keto acid,
and that's because
here's a acid group.
The ketone is alpha to
the carboxylic acid.
This would be in contrast
to this molecule.
So I'll just draw with
a generic R group.
Where here, the ketone is
beta to the carboxylic acid--
alpha, beta.
So pyruvate is an
alpha keto acid.
This here is a generic
beta keto acid.
Now I want to point out that
decarboxylations of bait ketone
acids are very
favorable, and they're
favorable for the
following reason.
And that's because if I remove
this CO2 from a beta keto acid,
I'm left with this molecule,
which hopefully you'll
recognize as an enol.
And just like we talked
about for the pyruvate kinase
reaction, enols much prefer to
rearrange into the keto form.
And so decarbonization
of a beta keto acid
generates an enol which will
rearrange to the ketone.
This becomes very
favorable, and so it
becomes favorable to
decarboxylate a beta keto acid.
Now, we can't use that
exact same chemistry
to decarboxylate
an alpha keto acid.
However, we can
help that process,
effectively mimicking
the same thing that
happens with beta keto acid, by
instead introducing a cofactor.
So I introduced the
concept of cofactors
when we talked
about NAD and NADH.
And remember,
cofactors are molecules
that provide functional
groups that help
facilitate the chemistry
of various reactions.
And so there's a cofactor that
facilitates the chemistry that
allows decarboxylation
of alpha keto acids,
and that cofactor
is abbreviated TPP+,
which stands for the
thiamine pyrophosphate.
TPP+, which is derived
from the vitamin thiamine,
sometimes also referred
to as the vitamin B1.
And so this is what
TPP+ looks like.
OK.
So like many of our
vitamins or cofactors,
it's a complex molecule.
So this is vitamin
B1 or thiamine,
and the cofactor TPP+ is
basically the same molecule
with a pyrophosphate group
added on the end, TPP+.
Now, to see what's
going on, we're
going to focus here just on
this part, this reactive part
of the molecule, which is right
here, which for simplicity, I
will just draw like this.
So this here is just this
basically part of the molecule
here, that's the
reactive part of TPP+.
And what makes this
cofactor useful
is that this basically can exist
in this stabilized carbanion
form.
This stabilized carbanion
can react with alpha keto
acid like pyruvate, shown here.
And then this
intermediate now becomes
favorable for decarboxylation
of the CO2 that's
alpha to the ketone.
And then here, we can regenerate
the active TPP+ that we started
with plus the other
product, acetaldehyde.
And then that acetaldehyde
can then be reduced,
regenerating NAD+ and giving
alcohol for fermentation.
OK.
Now incidentally, this is
how you produce alcohol.
How you metabolize
alcohol is effectively
reversing that last step
and further oxidizing
the acetaldehyde.
And so this is ethanol.
So the way ethanol
is metabolized.
And so the famous alcohol
dehydrogenase enzyme
basically does that
reverse reaction,
generates 2 electrons
as a hydride ion.
They get transferred to NAD+.
That NAD+ gets reduced to NADH
as this alcohol in ethanol is
oxidized to the aldehyde
in acetaldehyde.
And this can then be further
oxidized, that aldehyde
to the acid.
So here again, two electrons
from the hydride iron can
reduce NAD+ to NADH.
And that generates,
in the process,
oxidizes the
aldehyde to the acid.
In this case, this is acetate.
The acid form it would be acetic
acid, also known as vinegar.
And so effectively, the way
you turn alcohol into vinegar
is by the
microorganisms oxidizing
the alcohol they produce
into acetic acid or vinegar.
Now note, this is--
alcohol metabolism is
two oxidation reactions.
So we talked about last
time, oxidation reactions
are generally favorable,
therefore energy is released.
This is why alcohol
has calories and it's
impossible to make diet
alcohol, because it will--
just no way around this.
A couple other things
about this, as I mentioned.
This enzyme catalyzes.
This is the famous
alcohol dehydrogenase.
This enzyme is an
aldehyde dehydrogenase.
The issue is is that
this aldehyde hydrogenate
is a less efficient enzyme
than alcohol dehydrogenase,
thus it can become rate-limiting
for alcohol metabolism.
And so if you
overwhelm the system
by drinking too much,
effectively this enzyme can't
keep up with this
enzyme, you generate
excess of the toxic
acetaldehyde product.
Acetaldehyde product is
toxic, and this is effectively
what generates hangovers.
It's also the case
that there are
individuals with polymorphisms
of this aldehyde dehydrogenase.
This was, I believe, discussed
in Professor Yaffe's lectures
on enzyme kinetics that have
different catalytic efficiency
at this step, and the people
who have those polymorphisms
can't metabolize
alcohol as well.
They tend to get flushing and
whatnot because they build up
this toxic acetaldehyde,
and in fact,
can be quite dangerous
if they drink too much.
Finally, this also
illustrates effectively
why when commercially you
want to generate alcohol,
like in beer or a wine, you
need to keep oxygen levels low.
Why is that?
Because, well, the microbes
will read their ethanol.
It's a perfectly good source
of calories for them as well
because of these reactions.
But they generate all this
electron waste in the process.
Those electrons have
to go somewhere.
Where do they go?
Well, oxygen is a great
electron acceptor.
And so to metabolize
this ethanol,
they need to put those
electrons somewhere.
They need to put them
on oxygen. And so oxygen
is required to carry out
this ethanol metabolism
by the microorganisms.
And so by keeping oxygen out
of your fermentation of alcohol
in commercial beer
and wine production,
it prevents the formation
of aldehyde and acetic acid
products which would be
undesirable in your finished
drink product.
OK.
Now this whole
discussion also begins
to suggest one big way in which
glycolysis itself is regulated,
and that's effectively by
the availability of oxygen.
And so to be
explicit about this,
I want to draw the relationship
between fermentation,
glycolysis, and oxygen in
terms of maintaining electron
balance across these pathways.
And so glucose is, of
course, a major fuel for us.
It's a major sugar in our blood.
Yeast use a lot of
glucose from the grapes
in their environment.
Plants, of course, make glucose
as a storage carbohydrate.
It's-- we discussed, starch is
a polymer of glucose that uses
glucose to survive the night.
And effectively what they
do is turn that glucose
into two pyruvate
molecules which
can be used to generate
net 2 ATP as we discussed.
But creates this problem that it
also generates NADH that needs
to be recycled back to NAD+.
In the absence of oxygen,
you can ferment that pyruvate
into lactate or alcohol or some
other product that allows you
to regenerate NAD+.
Or-- and this is a pathway
that requires no oxygen.
However, that pyruvate can
be further oxidized to CO2,
but that's going to generate
even more electron waste.
That electron waste also
has to be dealt with,
and that requires oxygen
or some other place
to put those electrons,
oxygen to water
being a major driver of
further oxidative metabolism.
Now the beauty of
fermentation as a pathway
is that no oxygen is
needed, but the trade-off
is that it's much
less efficient.
You only get 2 ATP per
mole of glucose that's--
2 moles of ATP per of
glucose that's fermented.
You can imagine that a lot
more energy is released--
if you can further oxidized
glucose, you can generate,
therefore, a lot
more ATP if you use
a complete oxidation of glucose,
but this requires oxygen.
And so a major way that
glycolysis and certainly
fermentation is regulated
is that low oxygen
is what promotes fermentation,
whereas high oxygen suppresses
fermentation, and
that makes sense.
It's intuitive.
You get a lot more energy.
If you completely
oxidize your glucose,
you can more
efficiently get energy
from oxidation of available
reduced glucose carbon
if you do it by
oxidative pathways,
and so therefore, in the
presence of plenty of oxygen,
you don't need to
do fermentation.
Whereas if you outstrip
oxygen supply, as, say,
might happen if your muscles
are exercising, burning more ATP
than can be kept up with by
oxygen delivery from the blood,
now you switch over to a
more affirmative metabolism,
something like
lactic acid builds up
that can then be
dealt with later.
Now, this fact that high oxygen
can suppress fermentation
is experimentally true in many
organisms in many contexts.
It's likely because
the high ATP-ADP that's
produced with oxidative
glucose metabolism
can directly affect some steps
or deplete the NAD that's
required to drive glycolysis.
Exactly the
mechanism that causes
this is somewhat
debated and likely
depends on context
and conditions.
But it also sets
out at least a way
for us to begin
discussing, how is it
at a level of individual
enzymes or reactions might
something like high
ATP-ADP ratio effect flux
or flow through a pathway?
All right.
Well, let's just
start by talking
about what are the two
things that could affect flux
or flow through the pathway?
Well, remember,
thermodynamics, delta G,
is what determines whether
a pathway happens at all.
And because delta G is
proportional to things
like the ATP-ADP
ratio, you can imagine
if this ratio gets too
high, some of the steps
might no longer be
favorable to occur.
That's certainly
one possibility.
But the other way that
regulation can be done
is actually kinetic, and this
is because even though enzymes
don't determine whether
a reaction can happen,
at least thermodynamically,
they oftentimes
do determine the
rate of the reaction,
and when we're talking about
rate and flow through--
flux through pathways,
flow through pathways,
now rate can become
very important.
And so the kinetics of
enzymes, exactly what
you talked-- heard about with
Professor Yaffe, properties
like V max or Km of an
enzyme, which, of course, can
be affected by allostery,
and Professor Yaffe covered
in great detail, these
also, you can imagine,
can affect how a
pathway is regulated.
And of course, things like ATP,
ADP, and AMP as small molecules
can be good allosteric
affectors of some enzymes.
And so let's now
talk about, if we're
going to regulate steps in a
pathway, which steps should
actually be regulated.
And so shown here is, again,
coming back to our delta G
change map across glycolysis,
as we alluded to earlier,
the steps where
it's hard to go back
is this hexokinase step, this
phosphofructokinase step,
and this pyruvate kinase
step, because these
are where there's the
big change in delta G
that now makes it hard
to reverse those steps.
And it's exactly those
steps that are regulated,
because that makes sense.
If this delta G is
thermodynamically driving flux
through the pathway,
changing the rate
of the enzymes that
catalyze those steps
is also going to change the rate
at which the pathway as a whole
can happen.
Now as a result, it's
these steps, hexokinase,
phosphofructokinase,
pyruvate kinase,
that are often referred to
as the rate-limiting steps
of glycolysis.
Personally, I don't like
referring to memorizing things
like these are the rate-limiting
steps of the pathway,
because in reality,
what step of any pathway
is going to depend
on the context.
However, often this concept
of rate limitation when people
refer to pathways
really is coming
from this energetic
argument about which steps
have the biggest drop in delta
G, and it's important for you
to understand that,
not just memorize
what steps are rate-limiting.
Now I also want to point out
that these steps actually
are in interesting
places in glycolysis.
So this is basically
entry into the pathway,
and this is exit
from the pathway.
And this makes sense, too.
You don't want to
start committing carbon
into a pathway unless you're
actually going to need it,
and you also need to
match output to input.
And what you'll see is
that many steps in pathways
that are regulated,
in addition to being
the ones with the
biggest delta G changes,
are also often the entrance and
exit from the pathway, which,
of course, is the
case in glycolysis,
but also in most
pathways it makes
a lot of sense just from
logical considerations.
All right.
Now if we're going
to control things
that the level of
enzymes and rate,
how can we control
rate of a reaction?
That is, how can we
control enzyme kinetics?
Well, if you remember from
Professor Yaffe's lectures,
you can increase the rate
of a reaction-- that is,
catalyzed by an enzyme--
by increasing the Vmax
of that enzyme; or, if
the substrate concentration
is close to Km,
by lowering the
Km of that enzyme.
How can you decrease the rate?
Of course, you can
do the opposite.
You can decrease the Vmax; or,
if the substrate concentration
is close to Km, you
can increase the Km.
So how can I change
these things?
How can I alter Vmax or Km
of an individual enzyme?
Well, there's a number
of ways I can do this.
One is is I can
make more enzyme.
What will making more enzyme do?
Well, effectively that will
increase the Vmax of an enzyme.
Or if I get rid of
enzyme, that will
decrease the Vmax of an enzyme.
I can use a different
version of the same enzyme.
That is, have an enzyme
like pyruvate kinase
but have it come in a bunch
of different varieties,
have different genes encode
different pyruvate kinase
isoforms such that those
isoforms have different Vmax
and Km relationships with
respect to substrate,
and effectively, by
using a different version
of the enzyme, a so-called
isoform of an enzyme,
you can now have
different properties.
Now you'll note that
the change enzyme
kinetics this way basically is
new transcription translation.
That's fairly long
on the timescale
of needing to adapt to
metabolism, but that can work.
But sometimes a
lion's attacking you,
you need to run
away quickly, you
may not have time
to make more enzyme.
You also need direct
control of the enzymes,
and this is where allosteric
regulation of enzyme function
comes into play.
Allosteric regulation can
be a result of signaling.
Phosphorylate,
acetylate an enzyme,
that can change its properties.
Or you can have
metabolite binding.
Bind ATP, bind AMP into
some allosteric site
that can change Vmax or Km and
operate on a short time scale
to allow metabolism to adapt
in a more acute setting.
I want to say that time
scales matter for real biology
if you want to
understand physiology
and how it applies
to how metabolism
and physiology relate
to biology that you'll
encounter in other contexts.
You realize that some
responses need to be acute.
Those allow you to adapt
to conditions quickly,
be able to get enough ATP to run
away from the lion, et cetera.
But you also need
adaptations that
work on longer time
scales, because it's
things like this that allow you
to enact programs that allow
you to adapt long-term to
whatever new conditions a cell
may face in its environment.
All right.
Now, before I get into talking
exactly how these things
actually work to
regulate glycolysis,
I want to discuss a few
details about regulation
of pathways in general.
And while we talked about these
with respect to glycolysis,
these points will end up
coming up over and over again
and really apply
to other pathways.
Now I may not explicitly
point this out,
but the same considerations
for how glycolysis
works, how it's
regulated has to be
true for all metabolic pathways.
And remember, any
pathway is just
variations on relatively
few chemical--
chemistry reactions that
are repurposed in a way
to build some other thing
that's useful to the cell,
and you'll see this
over and over again.
Now, it has to be
true for every pathway
that it has to be
thermodynamically favorable,
and that means either that
the pathway itself, glucose
to pyruvate, is
thermodynamically favorable,
or it's coupled to some
kind of energy input,
like ATP hydrolysis that allows
the pathway to be favorable.
Every pathway is going
to be built in a way
that intermediates are
generated along the way that
allow that pathway to
accomplish its goals.
In the case of glycolysis
it was the two steps
that allowed us to synthesize
and incorporate phosphate
despite the high
ATP-ADP ratio in cells.
And in all cases
this has to obey
the laws of thermodynamics.
That is, we have to obey
constant conservation of mass.
That means we have to account
for all carbon, all electrons,
delta G has to be less than
0 across the entire pathway.
You'll see that the
regulated steps will often
be those with the largest
thermodynamic considerations,
like the big drops
across hexokinase,
phosphofructokinase,
and pyruvate kinase.
They'll often be at
the entrance and exits
to pathway because
you want to regulate,
you don't want to commit
something to a pathway
if you're not going
to use it, and you
want to match input and output.
And all of this is
going to have regulation
that acts on both short
and long time scales
so it allows it to
match physiology.
All right.
Now with that in mind,
now let's discuss
how we can regulate glycolysis
using both short and long time
scales as--
using really short time scales,
allosteric regulation of
glycolysis in a way that
makes it most useful to cells.
All right.
So the first step
is uptake of glucose
into the cell, which in animals,
like us, is passive, but can
still be regulated by glucose
transporters, often regulated
glute proteins.
And it's really these
glucose transporters
that can often determine
whether glucose is actually
taken up into cells.
A famous example of this
is FDG PET scanning,
which is used to measure glucose
uptake into tissues in humans,
where basically a
hydroxyl group is replaced
with a positron-emitting
fluorine
atom, fluorodeoxyglucose, that
is taken up and phosphorylated
in cells, and it's
this lighting up
of this on a
positron-emitting scan
you can tell that which tissues
in the body take up glucose
and that's a property
of cancer, and so it
is often used as a way to
detect or stage cancer.
Another example of
this is insulin.
Basically one of
the major actions
of insulin on your tissues
is that when glucose is high,
your body makes more insulin.
That causes glucose
transporters to be
put on the surface of
your muscle and your fat,
which allows that glucose
now to get into those cells
and effectively
allows those cells
to dispose of the
glucose in the blood
and keep glucose in the
right physiological range.
And so uptake of glucose,
at least in animals,
is one important step that is
really controlled largely by
whether or not there is a
transporter on the surface.
All right.
Once that's trapped as--
sorry, once it's in
the cell as glucose,
hexokinase then
traps that molecule
as glucose 6-phosphate.
And it turns out the
glucose 6-phosphate
is an inhibitor of hexokinase.
Why is that?
Well, we will see
in the next lecture
that glucose 6-phosphate
can be turned
into glycogen in the
case of mammals or starch
in the case of plants.
And so glucose 6-phosphate, if
you're going to store glucose,
you can ship it
off into glycogen,
or you could commit it
further down into glycolysis.
But if you don't need
it for a glycolysis
and your stores are full, you'll
build up glucose 6-phosphate,
you want to inhibit hexokinase
to keep things from flowing
through the system.
The next step that's regulated
is phosphofructokinase.
So phosphofructokinase,
of course, makes FTP.
The step downstream of
that that's regulated
is pyruvate kinase,
PEP to pyruvate,
and it turns out that FTP will
stimulate pyruvate kinase,
whereas PEP will inhibit
phosphofructokinase.
Makes sense.
You want to match
input to output.
If you have a lot of
FTP, activate the enzyme
to dispose of it.
If you're building up PEP, tell
you to stop sending molecules
down the pipeline.
It turns out, PFK is actually
the major regulatory step
of glycolysis,
because this is really
what commits that carbon
to going through glycolysis
as opposed to upstream of that,
it could be stored or not.
So it's really that step
that's a commitment step.
And so it's also
regulated by some
of the outputs of the pathway.
And so some of those
outputs are ATP downstream
of pyruvate, which we'll talk
about later in the course.
There's some other molecules.
Alanine, citrate.
It turns out that high levels of
citrate will also inhibit PFK.
High levels of ATP will
inhibit phosphofructokinase.
Whereas high levels of AMP will
activate phosphofructokinase.
Makes sense.
A major output of glycolysis is
to keep the ATP-ADP ratio high,
the energy charge
high in the cell.
If the energy
charge is very high,
high ATP, shut off
phosphofructokinase,
don't need to do
more glycolysis.
If the energy charge
low, high AMP,
activate phosphofructokinase.
If production of other molecules
downstream like citrate
are high, come back
and stop sending things
into the pathway.
Turns out, alanine can inhibit
pyruvate kinase, another step
downstream.
Great.
This is effectively
general regulation,
allosteric regulation
of how glycolysis works.
And what I wrote is
was generally true
across different tissues, but
of course, these regulations
can be tweaked to be more
or less important to match
physiology and function.
Now I know many of you are
going to take the MCAT.
And while I would never want
to teach just to take a test,
a couple of things
that you should
remember for that test
is phosphofructokinase
is a major regulator.
Its big allosteric regulators
are AMP, as well as
ATP and citrate.
Whereas the other
steps, hexokinase,
you should know that it's
regulated by-- negatively
regulated by
glucose 6-phosphate,
and pyruvate kinase is
positively regulated by FBP.
Now one other point
that I want to mention,
just because it will come
up sometimes on MCAT exams,
is that there's an additional
detail about how PFK is
allosterically regulated, and
that's because there's this
side reaction where
fructose 6-phosphate can be
phosphorylated on the 2 rather
than the 1 position to make
this molecule, fructose
2,6-bisphosphate.
This is a reaction that is
catalyzed by bifunctional
enzyme called PFK-2/FBPase.
So basically phosphofructokinase
on the 2 position, FBPase,
we're moving it from the 2
position which allows you
to regulate the levels of
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate.
It turns out that PFK in
glycolysis, which, of course,
generates FBP, is positively
regulated by fructose
2,6-bisphosphate.
And the production of fructose
2,6-bisphosphate is something
that can be inhibited
by ATP, inhibited
by phosphoenolpyruvate,
and activated by ATP.
So exactly what is shown here
is allosteric regulation.
Just some of this allosteric
regulation is via this side
enzyme to make a
separate product,
fructose 2,6-bisphosphate,
and there's control theory
considerations for
why that might happen.
All right.
So at this point, we've learned
how we can start with glucose,
oxidase that glucose
via a pathway that
now allows us to get the energy
that cells need to maintain
ATP-ADP ratio in a good
physiological range
despite the high
ATP-ADP ratio in cells.
However, it should also be clear
that in order for this to work,
we need a way to actually get
that glucose from somewhere
to begin with.
You probably learned
in high school
that plants use
photosynthesis as a way
to get energy from the sun.
Well, the synthesis
part of photosynthesis
is generating the sugar
that those plants can then
use to burn and keep
ATP-ADP high at night
and survive the night until
the sun comes up again
when they can again use
energy from the sun directly
to get energy.
We as animals evolve the way
that we have to eat the plants.
We have to get the glucose
that the plants make,
but of course, we also use--
generate-- have the ability
to generate some glucose,
and this is best illustrated
from muscle physiology.
And that is, we
alluded to earlier,
that if we're running
away from the lion,
our muscles might outstrip the
supply of oxygen in the blood
and basically generate
a whole lot of lactate.
Well, that lactate is
perfectly good fuel.
Just like the yeast, can oxidize
or we can reoxidize ethanol.
We can also use lactate as
a fuel, but it turns out,
a big job of our liver
is to take that lactate
from the blood, as well
as other molecules,
and regenerate glucose so
that our blood glucose remains
in a constant level.
This cycling of
glucose and lactate
across the body between
the muscle and the liver
is sometimes referred
to as the Cori cycle
and involves a clear
set of reactions
to turn that lactate
back into glucose,
a process called
gluconeogenesis.
And unfortunately we're
out of time today,
but next time I will
start off the lecture
by going through how it is
that gluconeogenesis works
to turn something like
lactate back into glucose so
that organisms have
the glucose to begin
with to run glycolysis.
Thank you.